Two, three, four!
Oh, wait. We almost forgot
about our special guest.
Helpsters!
Santigold!
Helpsters, we start looping our
sounds when Santigold tells us
and then stop
when she stops singing.
Sound good?
Oh yeah,
sounds great.
All right, Mr. Primm.
You got this.
Ready? Hit it!
[VOCALIZING]
[SNAPPING]
All right, sounding good.
Scatter!
[VOCALIZING]
[SNAPPING]
All right, Heart. You got this.
Yeah, you do.
Heart!
[BEATBOXING]
Woo! All right.
Cody.
Yeah? Oh, I'm next.
And go!
[VOCALIZING]
[BEATBOXING]
♪ I like mittens on my hands. ♪
♪ I highly recommend
that one big fluffy pocket ♪
♪ so your fingers
can be friends. ♪
♪ Mittens can't be beat
for keeping body heat. ♪
♪ Socks are super too, ♪
♪ they're like the mittens
of the feet. ♪
♪ So call me smitten. ♪
♪ Yeah, call me smitten. ♪
♪ I like mittens. ♪
Oh, that was so great,
Santigold! Thank you.
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪